and while she just corrupted my brain
you should ate volumes I'm like oh
that's short
[Music]
that's nice it's still it's still like
it's still like 100 chapters there's
still something about it yeah yeah it's
ridiculous it's disgusting yeah [__]
one piece man
that corrupts anyone's mind once a one
piece you're always a one-piece fan I'll
get that yeah yeah I know I feel like oh
gee manga I was also corrupted my brain
as well in terms of what a long manga is
because I realized
um like Shonen Jump manga are a lot
shorter than what they used to be right
because I thought into like I think back
and I think back to the big three
I thought of the big three bleach always
seemed like the shortest one you know
out of out of all of them right it
didn't it didn't it's uh it didn't and
it's definitely not short on the granite
scale it felt shorter than like let's
say my hero Academia is right for
example right to me it's not saying it
is to me looking back to like how
bleacher fated like my life and how long
I followed bleach it felt like it was
shorter in my mind
um and it's like 700 chapters I'm like
what yeah it's like 60 something volumes
what suppose bleach was this long what
that's crazy that's just so long yeah
but when but like I remember moments
where like I would read all of bleach
and I'm just like oh yeah yeah like it
was like like you know when I had the
stomach flu I really read slam dunk
right like and and it just [__] flew
by for me it's 31 volumes yeah and I'm
like this does not feel like 31 volumes
like if you think about 31 volumes of
anything that's long yeah but and it's
like almost 300 chapters and I'm like
how did I manage to just like fly by and
it just felt like nothing but then when
I try and sit down and read something
like like my hair for example it's just
like it's just one of a [__] back to
go talk it feels like 900 volume
you just like God stop this character
from doing anything please he ruins the
show so much actually actually I caught
up to the latest why why I caught up to
the latest uh what season are we at
right now we're at season six what the
[__] yeah right we had season six what
yeah
um yeah I mean I'm still here how are
they pumping this [__] up season three
I'm still I'm sitting here still
thinking we're on like season like four
I thought I got a genuinely I don't even
know uh [__] I'm so confused okay go
yeah go on yeah I will say yeah I will
say to to the Critter of my hero fans it
is it is the strongest season for a
while is it worth catching up to no
if you don't like my hero if you fell
out of love with it would I recommend
catching up for this uh no or what I
will say what I will say now is I'm like
kind of prefer backyard as a main
character oh my God I have a Deku Deku
the more who sucks the more seasons yeah
go I don't think it's saying that bakigo
is better than Deku is any any credit
tobacco all right Declan also [__]
sucks yeah there's a [__] like like
going into like the later Seasons I'm
like man take care bako has his problems
as a person but at least he's
interesting dude the more seasons I
watch the more I just feel like he's a
[__] wet bag oh my god dude oh he's
just he's just like a soccer at least at
least biker girl has got that spice yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's fine
I mean it might be a pepper Ball but
like it's still spots dude I still look
back and that that like three episode
bit with the British bad guy on her
little [__] thing that [__] felt like
10 years if you haven't watched my hair
academies just one stupid fellow Arc
with this basically British man as the
villain yeah and his his the reason he's
the villain is because he's British um
which is fair enough yeah that's valid
uh but it's just like the longest three
episodes of any anime I've ever watched
is that the one where they like shoe
Horner concert scene into it I think
they like try and like maybe I think
they like take up they try to like
invade the school and it was just so it
was again I've never had three episodes
of anime feel so long
it felt dude I I've read I've had like
I've read one piece like six hours that
went by way quicker than those three
episodes yeah yeah yeah insane how [__]
that show was at that point I mean I'm
sure it's better like I I mean like it
felt like at times it had moments of
really good character writing like when
a few scenes would like Endeavor and
stuff like that I really liked how they
had kind of oh they really zoned in in
endeavor's character Arc which for sure
which I knew they were going to do and I
really like that but not enough to get
back into it yeah yeah it's it's weird
because I could see with this latest Arc
that you know they tried to pull out all
the stops everyone gets involved they
ain't they ain't no High School hijinks
anymore like thank God every every
[__] hero comes out people [__]
die
um people actually die yeah people are
actually like God [__] [__] goes down
um shigaraki becomes so [__] opiate I
I feel like the made him op for the sake
of just like having to make a video
shoot again he's the kid
yeah and I could see them them pulling
out all the stops and I could see them
trying really hard
but it just something it's just missing
something I don't I don't even know what
it's missing it's just missing
some magic that I can't do you like the
main villain do I like the main villain
the three seasons I watched I was kind
of like who asked I was like
yeah my power is that I can jack myself
off with all these hands it's like okay
I never understood that character it was
three seasons in and I'm still like what
is this dude's deal yeah it's it's
pretty weird right because we get to see
his backstory
um I'm not gonna spoil what happens in
this backstory but if you like lay it
out on paper it's actually pretty
[__] dark what happens uh in his
backstory
um and I don't know why it just didn't
feel dark you know it it is something
about it was just like like the
presentation of it
I think it's just because it happened in
the My Hero World there was just this
like this very like uh like everyone's
wearing like a like a mattress around
them at all times right oh yeah all you
bandsters like it always feels like
everyone's wearing at home yeah yeah
I am I was watching the backstory I'm
like damn this is this is like some
pretty dark [__] that's happening right
why doesn't it feel that way yeah
why don't I feel like any emotions
towards some of the [__] up [__]
that's happening and then I watch some
some you know and then you watch
something that happens in like one piece
or like one piece which has like a very
let's say it has a unique art style that
doesn't touch dark and cartoon yourself
like that and some things happen in them
that's I don't know if it's a me thing
but Eve like when something dark happens
in one piece it [__] it feels dumb
yeah for sure um even though no one
contrasts on the world pretty well yeah
yeah I don't know there's I I haven't
thought I've put enough thought into it
to really pinpoint what's my hero in my
mind is missing you do the prize or
something how you six how many episodes
is that total how many episodes is that
like 100 plus
I think so yeah yeah holy [__] I I
salute you sir
the last season I finished was uh yeah I
think after the British guy showed up
that was the last year was that three or
four season three I think Seasons
it's insane to me that I watched four
seasons of that that felt like two so
you got further than I did oh no I feel
like my Approach with anime is a very
similar approach with you like Netflix
documentaries you know I play leave it
on yeah yeah sometimes I leave it on and
then the you know if there's boring
Parts in the anime I just it's kind of
just on in the background and I'm like I
can follow on with what follow along
with what's going on but like if it's
uninteresting I just don't get invested
and then I come back and sit down when
it's like okay shit's going down now
[__] shit's happening uh and season six
to its season six of my hero to its uh
credit has been like me sitting down
being like Oh I want to see what's
happening because shit's going down
um but it just hasn't hit on the same
level as chainsaw man even [__] Demon
Slayer you know isn't it crazy how my
hair Academia felt really new and fresh
him out yeah and now it feels so stale
and outdated yeah it's kind of crazy how
quickly that happens it's it's weird
it's it's nobody talks about my hair
anymore it's very few I feel like
because it's it's being outshined by its
competitors in one aspect like Demon
Slayer I think has less interesting
characters than my hero characters but
it's the spectacle of Demon Slayer it's
just on another level for sure um and
then now we have like Jiu Jitsu Kaizen
and Chainsaw man which I feel have more
interesting ideas and characters than
the whole world of mine is sure as well
yeah I think they're more I think
they're more mature and I think the
whole the whole world is just a bit more
interesting than the whole the world of
my hero as well
um there's just so many things
um that I feel my hero is so close to
being a great show but there's another
show that does something better than it
and I just gravitate towards that show
the maturity factor I feel might play
like a big role in it right which is
interesting though because it's like
it's still shown in Jump Right but like
when you compare it to other Shonen Jump
series it's just something about it is
like
like child not childlike what's the word
cartoonish yeah almost it's like it's
like Saturday morning cartoon Vibe right
yeah I think it's got the training
wheels on yeah yeah it's like I got
murdered and it's like oh yeah oh it's
like you now
my dad poured a hot kettle on my face oh
oh you that's a that's a shame yeah
that [__] would be like like visceral
would be gross yeah because you watched
up to like season five of like my hero
right
so you saw some of the Todoroki um
character arcs yeah yeah where some like
you know you think about you lay it out
on paper yeah it's [__] it's like some
traumatic [__] things happened to
Todoroki he got [__] abused by his
dad and his mum his mum [__] burned
his face yeah and I'm like you lay this
out on paper you're like this is pretty
traumatic why does it not feel like it's
that serious yeah it does something
about it just something about it it's
just being like Oh yeah that's just
that's just a thing that happened as
fast oh Todoroki you're poor let's put
some Vaseline on it yeah yeah like if I
could go lost like both of his legs it
would be cute like everyone would be
like oh wow oh we used to figure out how
to use his powers differently you know
what I mean like yeah like you know what
I mean it's just kind of like weird how
it's uh it's just yeah yeah it's how
they make these serious moments feel
very like like I said like safe like it
feels like it's contained in this very
safe confines like yeah scary ideas
won't be explored like yeah bad thing
things will happen but the implications
of those ideas are never truly like uh
like like Todoroki is obviously like has
every right to be a character that has
trauma but I feel like they never ever
really delved into it in a meaningful
way no he's just I hate I hate my like I
hate my dad I hate my daddy issues yeah
well why don't we like actually just
[__] go into this and how that could
actually impact you obviously right I I
think it wouldn't sell manga like
talking about why Todoroki would be
traumatized and why seeing his dad would
like upset him you know like yeah it
feels that they they laid out all the
pieces and just didn't connect them
properly it felt like yeah and he's sad
and he hates his dad yeah yeah it's it's
just kind of like background noise right
I'm like it's not at the Falls it's not
the 15th rent we've done about my hair
again
I feel that's because it's such an
interesting case study in anime where
it's like there is very few it does
everything right but yet it doesn't feel
right right the reason I watched it is
because if I'm gonna [__] talk something
I wanna I wanna at least have watched it
and so I'm not talking out of my ass I
feel like four seasons I have every
right yeah I think I made it far enough
oh you can you can say blue lock maybe I
don't because I don't know what's wrong
I did a season and a half so that counts
here on trash days we have uninformed
rants about a lot of things but I refuse
to I refuse to bring that to anime as
well man I'm sure this podcast is the
epitome of where's your souls I made it
the [__] up deal with it